welcome amination time that's right
bringing it back gamer with a custom
story this one's called spell o spook
fest ah that's not a real button ah so
spooked oh my god they changed the
loading screen nothing like playing a
horror game in broad daylight listen
finally it's October spook month I urge
you to stop for a moment and smash like
on this video if you're excited for
spook Tober and listen in that
atmosphere sorry it replaceable I mean
there's probably some other stock audio
you keep it in thick I mean no I'm so
hype epic I have no idea what if this is
even scary by the way you've invited to
a party by a talking skeleton Wow
sorry for breaking the mood alone you're
fine just let me play Jesus Christ
ah the good old Brendan Berg bringing it
back nothing spear loose epic it looks
legit I don't remember seeing this kind
of stuff during the custom amnesia
Dame's days a good old custom story
remember those remember those I don't
know it was actually one of you guys in
the comments I recommend I played this
and I'm like yeah I want to do it it's
been so long so Sachi buried this oh
Jesus Christ
forgot how loved this game is hi Ralph
Stefano
is it me Eric I can't see anything huh
Alessi is a Swedish team oh there it is
Wow oh no I forgot I'm playing a horror
game get up stop
yep oh okay we're fine
Jennifer it's you ah let me touch you
Jennifer let me rub sorry I'm sorry I'm
here for Halloween
what let me end I'm out how do I check
journal again it's right here
notepad that XC spooky stirs what am I
supposed to do again I'm too hard to
climb up the hole
look around for tools and supplies shut
up you crazy stone you're not at all Oh
chief sorry Mia yeah you spooked me
can't get through here take my chair
dumb
oh come on hold the door open shut well
I thought I grabbed it in their box all
right now I have some self-defense
bring it oh I'm not afraid of anything
oh god it's dark keep me company
Jane miss Jennifer the search breaks
stop
oh very sturdy investors hint throw did
it
damn it's actually kind of scary I'm not
gonna lie
that doesn't work what do i do then I
need a lantern maybe I can move these
hello but I need a key one key Abby had
a 500 I get it I'm supposed to spin the
wheel that's it
I'm supposed to spin the wheel
I'm joking I know I'm not supposed to
did I miss something back here what's
there really a key what happened to the
tinderbox oh I used it love you
shovel all right whatever guys we got
shovel yes
I literally stole tinder box literally
stole it we can move this if we hold
shift I think no it's stuck there isn't
it oh that throw though shut up I'm
trying to figure out what I missed
maybe I'm Lily just to throw supposed to
throw the stone why did I use it there
you dummy it was reflex I can't help my
small brain can't wait to freak out all
my neighbors in Japan because I'm
screaming like an idiot okay here we go
you just do this oh my god I went back
in goddamn homes I swear I threw it
stupid useless stone hey stupid useless
stone stone Oh God no come back
I love you
don't leave me I'm all alone
ah freak now ya know hello
I bring your stone I bring a stone go
ah come on hello hey hey hey hey it's me
Swedish minecraft player I'm spooked you
got me I'm spooked Oh God Oh
eros I knew it I freaking knew it like I
said it so many times it must be the
barrels aha
Frank okay finally some good freaking
light
what's making that sound hey hey a book
hello book can I pick you this up what
is the point then oh god oh god hello oh
god no okay this is sexy man oh you're
not gonna move are you right okay we're
fine well I'm spooked brah what's making
scratching noises sorry I literally
can't see anything unless my face is
dilute to the screen this is what I get
for playing during day okay we're good
we're good we're good gamers we're good
it's no problem
I'm not even scared not even the
slightest bit of spook right now if
there was a spooky meter it'd be set to
4 which is some spook I know but okay
we're fine ah barrels
oh look escape out epic stinky oh I
found something did you see that
brah I'm so good at games people don't
understand shop
hope hope what is this la da na dhanam I
found it finally I searched everywhere
for let another nun
let her let the net at them stink stink
you all stink yes I'm good
I got tinderboxes stone stone okay let's
just go down sorry I mean to make sure I
gave her everything
I'm taking you hostage that's right
stink you smell like stinky dum dum
barrel hate you ruin my life ten years
but you're the one work for mainstream
me classic place to hide things in video
games underneath the stairs
always check the stairs gamers okay
maybe now this time there wasn't
anything but you're still you're stinky
smell oh no hey hey oh hey he's coming
stink stink don't stop
okay we hide hide hide hide
you better not freaking tell him okay
we're fine he was just smelling the
stink from you dumb so dumb hey hey okay
spook Manor is officially at five hey
hey
hello 100 always check the signs first
they want you to go they want you to go
to the light but that's just it stink
they want you to go to life first that's
an old trick tinder in there yes freak
hate you you smell like a rotten egg
dumb Rutan brain God I'm slowing this
game what
there's Bowles in Minecraft spooky meet
her down to four no problem not even
scared Frick spook Peter six I'm running
taking the pole with me though that's an
old trick
there's an old gamer trick it's a hat
trick you come with me hat it's fine
I'll just go here go to the light you'll
never find me in life
ah I need kiawe oh god I think he's
coming oh oh oh
bucum either Sabbath oh hey the [ __ ]
please don't come here how am i alive
Oh God Oh
I just passed two seconds spooky not too
happy okay spook continues you got to
realize it's just epic okay let's take
it easy
Oh spook eight no spook is eight focus
nine if you don't blink
he can't blink if you don't blink
he can't blink no what do you want why
does he not go away he's
you stink it's cool
No what am I supposed to do running I'm
going for a gamer's pro-gamer move in
three two one
let's go uh-huh yeah not afraid spooky
meter two and a half thousand Oh God
oh yeah easy peasy lemon squeezy Kitty
feeling very frizzy nipples
Maxo MASMA Jesus there's Jesus in
Minecraft
hello my sweet my crotch oh oh oh hat
came back let me wear it on my peepee
oh there's rats in Minecraft lanterns
Manton yes yes I literally stole it
don't even care yes Apple Snapple mmm so
good so good mmm good hmm I got an idea
we put the Apple on the barrel we throw
Apple on the barrel and say stinky
that's awesome I like that idea
hey hey gotta take it easy
stinking thank you you smell stinky so
stinky oh you smell like rotten apple
what your mama couldn't buy food you
stinky stinky blinky dumb huh your son
is a full of stink dumb this game is not
good for my posture and my sight all
right you think this is one of those
moments you think you're gonna be fine
but I ain't taking no chances I'm going
full maximum speed oh yeah the Hat is
here it follows oh yeah Oh God
their spook is my the spook is man all
right here we go our new area I feel
fresh and clean clean clean hey hey this
is nice this is not so stinky yeah I
like this not very stinky at all in fact
just smells like
[Music]
oh okay meter 10 yeah what is this oh
yes Oh am I already there yes what do
you mean stuck I'm serious listen
Stephen I paid good money for this and
you're just a bad luck well that's great
but so I'm going to be stuck here until
someone fixes it I'll fix it buddy no
problem well this is a bit
claustrophobic now that I think about it
Stephens I mi Stephen what am I supposed
to do find a way to fix the show house
that morning spooky scary skeleton Oh
tada da da da da da da da da tada tada
da da da da da da da da tada
huh is it weird that I'm making my own
entrance music yes
well act well yet I think it is I am the
spooky skeletons fellows and you my
friend have not changed at all since
I've seen you last Christmas how have
you been old friend
wait Christmas no really do tell
go on I'm listening
epic gamer mhm yes that's need chipped
up chip chip no really
yep that's right and then I had a big
mouth that's interesting my pling plong
plong well enough chitchat my fleshy
friend before we have a great party in
front of us really actually before we do
that let's talk about last Christmas
just like I told the cops the
allegations
that we have murdered the Santa Claus
and single-handedly ruined Christmas
I'm telling you that might be true okay
fine and so is the part about me having
illegal weaponry but he did fly over our
property
so technically South defense well I did
tell all that to the sheriff and he
actually was very understanding an x-ray
he wrote everything down and now we're
wanted but don't let that break down
your spooky spirit never follow me well
this is something the south maybe not
yet oh you must be wondering where the
party immerse the party it's on the
other side of the castle hold on hold on
I utilized my bony ingenuity Europe ena
and created a trolley of sorts that will
effortlessly transport us to the party
itself what what are you looking at you
don't think I'm able to how dare you
well either way you're right I did not
make the trolley I just found it's here
and it's missing a few parts I need to
get the part good news they're in the
local storage and the South bad news a
crazy woman ghost haunts that place but
it's either a haunted dungeon or the
entire castle so chop-chop I'll wait
here until you find all the missing
parts because I swear she is the most
terrifying thing I've ever seen if it's
your mom
good luck cuz i boned her get it let's
go collecting spooks this is so weird
I can see a saw here it might be helpful
for sure seesaw
I see sir job bling blang blang blang
blang or they should have put something
there gamers had this back hello we're
for protection it's a shield
alright spook level zero I'm not afraid
of anything never been scared in my
entire life in fact what pazzo in
Minecraft how does it work Wow
brain so big brain extremely large Oh Oh
Frick oh hey hey hello oh this is tight
oh I don't like tight spaces except your
mom's sexy ass she says oh god he's not
coming in here is he damn bad hey hey
hello what am I supposed to do go here
oh it's a mosque I don't like those I
don't like those okay can I go yeah yeah
yeah we got this gamers easy easy
[Applause]
yeah all right sold it wish I was a
little slower to be honest let's see oh
did it did it gamers what's up what's go
see hey hey okay we go here then yes
hello
they look you dumb hey hey hey hey catch
are you broke yet you dum-dum you're so
dumb I need a key all right fine but
they broke the chair too stinky
what we got here we got a what is it
what is that a shoe it's a shoe and we
have a key okay that was easy
okay gig immerse no problem let's go
heigh-ho heigh-ho
Swedish noises hello oh it's a picture
of man with beard awesome spook level
constant story good is it references
what is this okay cool shoe here tako
dico dico dico we stole a high heel now
we just go back with the high heel and
then was that chair there before and
we're good to go
okay spook level was excite a point I'm
still gonna run hello
that's a trap god-king yeah
okay okay spiky spikes it's fine ah what
that ah that's really hard
Oh No dingdong ding a ling ow my face is
titties
what does that mushroom it's like man of
me Dan where I'm just the plot twist is
that I had drugs it's got a spook level
5 I just want to be honest with you guys
but okay what do I need I don't even
know what I need I'm just literally okay
watch out for the stinkies okay he came
from there all right we got dead stuff
he's not coming here is he
all right we got a drill this is not a
drill however hello all right let's
check out where he was
can we drill our way out okay
you could proceed oh I could leave but I
shouldn't nah nah ah frog see coming
here
I don't wanna die I don't wanna die I
wanna freak Oh what did I do
my sanity is low oh god it makes a
little freaky oh god I hate when the
senator leaves love oh god it's so
freaky sneaky I think it goes away after
a while but man is so annoying
oh I get it we used to drill in his bud
what where did the drill go what's the
point of drills if you can't drill holes
literally what my dad taught all right
let's check out here god this is
annoying
oh that's better that cured my amnesia
hey hey all right cool we're doing good
good move ah oh yeah you you left shift
now remember bucket dumb all right I
don't think there's anything here damn
did I throw that perfectly oh he's there
stinkies there so we have the hammer and
we have the drill what else can we need
possibly I'm stink I'm sticking out of
here this is where we came from
yeah I'm stinking out I'm stinking out
I'm stinky now
spook double-0 oh look I pimped our ride
epic get in loser we're going holy [ __ ]
didn't run
[Music]
hold on to your flesh human yeah oh yeah
this is so trippy
this is flopping
there are way oh damn son where did you
find this amnesia what happened to you
me going inside your mom be like I'm
sorry she's had wouldn't it be funny if
we were actually in hell not actually
that would be terrible now that I think
about it oh no no no no no I'm sure
that's just a phrase you know a little
light-hearted hyperbole yeah I need a
lawyer did somebody say my name Oh God
keep that off first of all no second of
all that is the flippin devil players
who don't read No welcome to the most
single most painful place in the
universe
excuse me mr. daylor inside your mom why
are we here ha ha ha ha ha you died
right but why are we in hell it looks
really good actually all right that's
fair so what happens to us now you will
suffer for eternity well if I may my
dear devil offer a counter-argument for
you are forgetting one important
attribute that might indeed save me and
my client from such terrible fate
and what is that well the simple fact
that we indeed can run for our lives
Oh God
exit others Nixon oh yeah how mothers
with dirty code
stinky code I guess we got to go out
there this became a platformer oh my god
oh oh oh okay we can't mess up now
Jesus I am here we go
[Music]
bellows and reputation epic to be david
mods yeah almost out that's all you have
to do just run out I kind of wanted to
check out the cafeteria to be honest oh
there's a man we did a gamer's we beat
amnesia teleporting naked guys no
freaking way
what that's such an old PewDiePie
reference or is it even a PewDiePie
reference oh my god he'll have to hold
the gate open God go through go-go-go
out the gamer moment yeah yeah we don't
have the time forget about me you gotta
go oh I wasn't wearing I just read ah
here we are
excellent Jesus is back hello Phoenix
give me kiss thanks my dearest friend if
you read this I got myself into a
situation from which I will never escape
knowing myself I probably destroyed the
whole world or got stuck in Hell or
whatever in any case I would like to
apologize for what you potentially may
or may not have gone through fair enough
fair enough
you were probably promised a party
that's right a party that will never
happen at least not with me this is so
sad I sincerely hope that my actions
brought a bit of happiness into your
life and if my crazy antics and weird
little jokes managed to create a smile
on your face for at least a while I
regret nothing please do not be sad for
we will meet again see you in hell the
spooky skeletons of loose ends
oh wait happy Halloween 2018 so this is
last year I didn't realize what a trip
back to the memory lane if they do a
2019 it might be fun to do it again at
the end of the month if you want to play
it check it out thanks for watching guys
fun as always fun to like go back to
amnesia every once in a while especially
there in October so yeah see you guys
smartest video subscribe check out merch
well you haven't tried to pursue me
later citizen e after 50 million out
troops by etch down just now it's still
relevant
just allottee